merci à gutenberg devenant ainsi le
dernier mot bonjour même temps 2-3 en
immersion
ces kits et qashqai tu sais même pas qui
s'est dissout pour la face à nous on
veut pas fou rien cassé son pour cet été
sauf que le quartier
[Musique]
or pour eux je suis animé plus
précisément dans les quartiers ouest ce
qu'on appelait la zus est considéré
comme un des quartiers les plus pauvres
de france il ya environ 15000 habitants
qui vivent ici dans 70 % vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté quand on entend parler
de ses quartiers dans les médias en
général c'est plutôt à travers des faits
divers notamment des fusillades qui ont
lieu régulièrement ici ou alors une
trafic de drogue qui prennent place
quand même assez importante mais moi
j'ai eu envie de vous montrer un autre
visage de ce quartier à travers les yeux
de ces artistes
ils se disent assurés soit des pavillons
vichy s'est mise en mode limitantes vous
dire merci car audio
savonnières le compère d'attaqué jour
sans compter
ces carrés alors moi c'est pour ça j'ai
maintenant
mais on commence à tomber à l'arrêt
monchy je vend tellement présente moscou
16 ans j'ai encore mon pote logistique
et de quoi vous parlez dans vos chansons
wiltz convives
porte ou encore dans le quartier mais
pourquoi c'est important pour vous de
vous présenter le quartier parce qu'on
est né ici à votre agrandissent issues
de cellules sud en fait
tu vois c'est qu'en est-il au nevada va
dire en gros la zup c'est
dans ce quartier doivent rendre ici on a
tout fait depuis gamin en fête
et de la musique alors ton crois que la
musique
ne sais pas si c'est une passion a fait
petit en fait gauche
j'ai grandi dans cinq mois la musique
avant on perdra pas aussi apprécié je
voyais les grandes parties tandis clip
au moins sept chinois
grâce à youtube est en voie d'ordonnancé
et hongrois c'est ça c'est un jour j'ai
vu huy s'il a mis en examen sur 100 sur
ce match est en fait qu avec chedjou à
la zone sud est ces médiateurs que
c'était moi c'est moi j'avais contacté
en privé nous a vraiment tout après un
pas dans la musique en elle-même pour
mieux informer c'est ça aussi
si bienvenue sur la bdl famille les i
c'est brutal
on est en studio le gtl gas to nîmes
plusieurs artistes qui font leur sont
ici on est chez moi 900
débrouille on a fait le match qu habits
bien je peux venir voir au moins ça
m'inspire et certains à faire pareil
c'est
[Musique]
alors en fait ça c'était la bibliothèque
ans ils ont démoli tu es belle les avait
jetés c'est des panneaux d'acoustique je
suis allée les récupérer je suis allé
faire la récup ont un beau panorama mais
voilà ça c'est mes trois tours de las
vegas où il
a tout mon quartier là
tout le quartier qui donne la force au
monde sait que tous parce qu'ayant n'a
plus assez dès ce
mois ouais
ça brille et le cachet partir d'ici en
ayant essayé d'ouvrir une porte pour que
ce soit plus facile pour les petits
frères justement parce que ces jo s'est
toujours
ramener un peu plus de gens vers nous un
peu plus d'ouverture
comme une structure way
propose des surfaces
ils ont sanctionné dans son budget -
contre eux alors je m'appelle l'ema mon
nom de scène c'est emma émerger j'ai 16
ans et j'ai commencé la musique depuis
le 4 janvier 2020
puis de reprendre du service au repos
nadal je vous lance abandonné les gens
comme ça se connait bien suivi j'attends
un mouleur on jamais plusieurs m'ont
rappelé fécondité sidya toure vacances
bafoue pas émergé dans toutes les phases
aurait peu d'effets majeurs sur wii
c'est pas de femmes dans le milieu
artistique
c'est une bonne question je pense que
pour moi les filles elles ont peur de se
lancer cl ont trop peur c'est les
préjugés ce que les garçons les filles
vous en pensez dans la rue ça va se
passer comment des fois il ya des filles
viennent me demander en privé ouais et
tous comment on fait pour ce que l'on
sait comment on fait tout ça à moi
aujourd'hui mais coûte one life tac une
vie parce que les gens ils parlent ils
parlent ils parlent surtout les 42
aujourd'hui tu vois je te dise ah bah
pas là c'est un quartier surtout tu as
tu es une fille fais gaffe à toi tu sais
jamais et ouais mais attends regarde je
fais de la musique avec magic notre vie
toi y'a pas de problème vous venez vivre
la zup en plus c'est le meilleur pivot
de nîmes 1 30 euro l'heure et veut avoir
de plus mr x sarah hanffou la dame à
tesco jette comme un micro foulée j'ai
peur de la mort je m'en sortir mais je
suis déjà fan et on qui est mat est trop
gentil même un docteur march dessus il
n'y a pas de trois collègues mon propre
père magali m'a déçu et je vois les gens
se consumer plus vite qu'une balle au
fond de la classe à l'école juge pas
mais les autres te mettre dans
classement obligé de se faire entendre
pour entendre parler de soi c'est pour
ça je ferme à tête devant l'équipe ça
serait la mère royaume on allait oublier
tout le monde passait ont commencé je me
taille pozzo du public
envers la famille c'est mon intérêt je
suis fatigué qu'on écoute et déjà luczak
les 3900 et monsieur c'est la guerre la
musique est de fort boyard
je pense pas qu'on a choisi la musique
nos sites en fait seule la gamberge soit
tu ma pause déjeuner c'est une bonne
question alors qu'à la bassée prix je
voulais écrire un livre moi je peux pas
faire cela c'est quoi je commence pareil
et j'avais en fait là où tu l'avais
choper juste avant
la première faute était parti et bien
démarrer le dollar on perd la foi mais
c'est mon intérêt chauffeur tchèque
entend écouter les jaloux tchatcher
bon c'est bon non
c'est quoi ces mêmes potentialités qui
t'intéresse c'est vraiment moyen
d'expression artistique
franchement c'est des deux agences et
les deux camps jeudi du mois je fais en
bac pro commerce alors aujourd'hui j'ai
pas envie de finir dans un magasin à
21h10 j'ai pas du tout envie moi turquie
et j'avais des crampes qui l'ont vue
d'un tuyau en musique des choeurs pour
les travaux et pis si bronze est de
commencer soit qu'ils m'appellent tu
fais ma vie en fait je me demande je
suis dans mon sens ils veulent que je
signe son basset noir
à domicile ses coiffeurs du tchèque
voilà je me fais un changement
de régime va le perdre à venir
je voulais couper la coupe 0 barde tout
compris tous
car si j'aime pas trop de duchesses
[Musique]
bientôt ici
tente de museler fond du problème
c'est
vraiment trop bien et où j'aimerais
faire croiser écoute pas les mêmes
personnes qui croisent et on se connaît
pas voyant pâtit je pense que témoin
sous x
ce
sont les gars et des
chanteurs de sortir des quartiers secoue
le premier justement pas la dernière
fonctionne c'est parce que j'avais je
suis allé un peu mais c'est parce que
j'avais des papiers un ferry on sortait
j'étais jeune on allait beaucoup en
ville mais maintenant c'est que les
jeunes aujourd'hui je le vois plus
longue vie me reste au quartier
peut-être une coïncidence pire ça y est
la musique le quartier
[Applaudissements]
et ouais ça c'est le quartier
ça s'écrit bord
merci le coffre ighil est ce que tu as
entendu c'est un cri ça prévient qu'il
ya la police
oui street
l'incident google annonce entre nous
parce qu'on veut dire à ceux qui
diraient contrôler la police ce serait
plutôt des airs on serait vite
visualiser tu comprends ce que je
m'étais le chiffre par rapport à la
tenue même par rapport à la façon dont
marche est peut-être le comportement
nous on est très expressif ça veut dire
actuellement on évite heureux on fait
vite au monde vit dans l'écrit dans les
gestes et sans affaires cessantes
crédits devenus sans choquer les gens et
surtout maintenant il ya des caméras
partout c'est surveillé donc dû course
dans mon quartier on sait qu'on en
sécurité c'est vrai c'est une sécurité
une sécurité mentale le quartier
nsr des coupons voilà pourquoi le rac
question pourquoi laura nous on a grandi
dans sa comme ci dessus et c'est ça qui
c'est avec ça qu'on s'exprime le mur je
n'aurais pas fait les heures studio
peut-être ailleurs nourricerie rentrer
en prison cela soulève le temps du
courage le camp de couilles peu des
balles pour nos plaines auto dit je suis
contre ce système où il y montre souple
à notre chance et radicale parce qu'on
sait déjà que this is it a décidé samedi
vers ses amis c est s
est
sorti ce matin là il est bien évident
qu'elle avait 13 ans
fait notre reportage
monsieur ville
en arrivant devant moi j'écris juste
pour garder les flots et où à la fin je
dois modifier quoique donc ça c'est un
peu mieux maintenant l'exemple j'écris
je suis moche et et du c4 si tu me
touches et moins chaudes et enfin si tu
veux toucher bien au prix de 4 le p4
scellé
outre les gamins jouer là mais en bas il
ya des caves en fait je mens par là
qu'en fait les clients y rentrer et
venez par la galerie comme ça ils font
pas chauffé choix c'est quoi j'ai trouvé
ce fou là il est
né
rentré comme ça avant j'étais né d'un
côté
c'est cette journée complète en
effet récemment son poste à l'écart et à
patates
[Musique]
et je vais essayer de faire une phrase
qui va finir par quand je rentre je
dessine quand on est en fait un titre
qui en fait l'un des 15 5 ans ne veut
pas d'un pétard quand je rappe chance
mais je trouvais le dernier mot
moi j'avance comme ça je peux trouver
même le dernier mot doit enfin juste
parce que je sais qu'il
doit accorder
qu'est ce qu'on a dit c'est
le cas c'est bien toi
il ya moins de deux ans je suis parti de
rien je démarre avec 200 g et de sujets
détaillé 120 volts dtn mais le biais des
rançons jour en jour je voulais tourner
dit rien pilote en voiture pétards tirés
des marchés sortent du lot à tous si
j'étais mange hécatombe et artes je
salue
mozilla j'ai grandi là j'habite au
quatrième dans la dernière fenêtre là tu
vois le petit boîtier mois là où il ya
quatre étages c'était chez moi
je sais 18 ans là
pour s'amuser sans même pas aller
chercher son mal en est
j'ai toujours pas changé depuis ses
bases ce message au maire de la ville
aux alentours on a fait toutes les
villas il reste plus beaucoup de feu ça
sur le béret qui commence à 6
mois je m'appelle willy paul cuisine
saine dans mon andrade tout simplement
mon blast tout court au moins six mois
j'ai grandi avec ma mère et
et mes deux soeurs manchester
je pars avec mon père
c'est pas choquant sinon je vais pas me
plaindre tout dire on a galéré pas grave
ils viennent se serait crashé sur le
travail de marchands
on s'est régalé ma mère elle a très bien
géré mais elle était seule à la gérer
fort et voilà je m'étais l'école à 15
ans j'arrête en troisième
j'aimais pas trop où je finis qui m'ont
vu ce
matin je te mens pas je n'ai pas trop
l'école ça je le vis très foot rend la
mauvaise boulot et j'ai réussi à trouver
un travail deux mois après que j'ai
quitté l'école donc ça va j'ai pu faire
un contrat d'apprentissage en vente jeté
dans un snack en centre-ville
au congrès j'en ai fait un
j'en ai fait du mieux sur save en salle
et ça fait pas ça d'enfer d'y aller ont
convaincu que les sorties à 8,6 jusqu'à
maintenant marié mois axa j'ai dû
toucher millogo non je crois que
d'argent
ouah âge les couilles de dieu
anarchiste pour moi c'est la créativité
on a tous le besoin de créer quelque
chose à se prouver quelque chose andré
tu vois je trouve c'est l'instinct
animal ce match il a su créer quelque
chose tu essayes ton cerveau il pousse à
avancer je pense tout simplement
peu importe que tu sois même un joueur
de ballon
c'est pour moi
merci
là bas merci
[Musique]
je suis
comme dirait talent à ce criminel c'est
vrai que je fais du rap ou jouer pour la
prière
[Musique]
c'est tout beau tout propre coup c'est
correct
or à moins tapis sur un bouton
[Musique]
sans attendre
sans les goûts
[Musique]
oh
on gagne notre vie dure aux membres à
grâce à la musique comme certains
croirait ouailles ont fait fuir des
kebabs on y arrivera on n'a rien sans
rien le gil j mg l
[Musique]
une fille c'est par apc pas jouer au
foot
voilà
attends attends
faut que je vois d'où je vais partir
j'ai envie de faire cette ligne moi
j'attends z camp pour voir ce qui va me
dire j'ai j'arrive à faire cette ligne
de l'ange quant au fond
tu en penses quoi de tout ce qui est à
côté du reste devant
et lui derrière
en bref au puc l'histoire se répète
jeter ce jeune au cours de la tarte qui
faisait le pitre en plus tard toujours
au country hall a détaillé du chêne
quand je cogite quand j'écris des taxes
et le tout souvenir d'enfance j'ai gardé
quand après lehman il rejeta they can
aujourd'hui ça des graines ben
franchement merci beaucoup d'être venu à
la du sud merci ça fait vraiment plaisir
même quartier et ça les a même river
quoi réveiller
[Applaudissements]
ça fait ça donne envie de rester dans le
truck baden la force en fait mourad ben
on met le sang
c'est parti c'est brut c'est brutal
[Musique]
a aimé cette vidéo vous avez appris des
choses il ya d'autres quartiers comme ça
en france que vous aimeriez qu'on met en
lumière chez les bretons n'hésitez pas à
le mettre en commentaire n'hésitez pas
non plus à like et la vidéo et à la
partager merci beaucoup et je vous dis à
très bientôt pitaro mais quand vous
voulez vous êtes la famille
c'est qu'on est devant moi
[Musique]